so I was at a restaurant a diner
actually that I like to go to I like to
go all the time me and the fellas we go
after after doing the show and we have a
good time I would go when we laugh and
by the way dude when I'm at this diner
or if I'm at a diner it doesn't need to
be this diner any diner after I do shows
and I'm with other people that are
friends other headliners other openers
other whoever it doesn't matter even
open my courage that I like it doesn't
matter we have a [ __ ] silly goose
time and that's it I got my opener Mike
who's sitting there probably thinking
dumb [ __ ] like that's crazy how birds
can fly and we don't fly you know and
then I've got my Irish buddy Marc who's
probably thinking although we're doing
the little um do la okay and I've got
Craig who sounds like this and has the
most French laugh of all time because he
goes hey okay and then there's Joe the
thing about Joe is he looks he couldn't
look more like he's from Chicago he also
for some reason always looks like he's
wearing a backpack even when he's not
one of the reasons why I go to this
diner is I like the food uh
who knew the people there know me they
know my orders and [ __ ] I love the food
okay that's the main reason though food
and ambiance is why I go if you're a
waiter or a waitress you can be addicted
me as long as the food in the ambience
is good or if you're really nice and the
food is good the ambiance can suffer a
little bit you get there's these three
things that I like so this restaurant
has all of them alright we get I get my
I get a chicken sandwich which is one of
my hot [ __ ]
one of the hot shits i order all the
time I get the tickets and or I get the
breakfast burrito or I get a breakfast
sandwich and you know what I like also
the fries okay so they drop the plate
and I notice that the fries are
different all right now I love the fries
it's one of the reasons why I go to this
[ __ ] because I love the food and part
of the food of the fries now everybody
at the table we all like the fries
that's why we go these fries are
different and Joe with his [ __ ]
always commenting on food [ __ ] he
says I got different fries they look
good okay
blood-curdling anger now let me tell now
let me explain now let me explain me
here okay first of all he's doing the
thing that he always does talking about
food now step one I take I take one step
up to anger heaven do you understand me
I'm taking one step up to anger heaven
okay and the the the waitress goes like
this oh yeah they're just temporary
we're gonna get two old fries back soon
in about a week but we got these now he
says oh they look good second step to
anger heaven okay so actually third step
that's the second step when she says
they're temporary okay
third step to anger heaven okay so now
let me tell you second step
she says they're temporary so now she
says they're temporary because she
thinks Oh Joe thinks they look good so
now she's going to [ __ ] think that
these she's gonna think about these in a
favorable way now we like the fries
already now their new fries he hasn't
tried him at all he just said they look
good now she's got that positive [ __ ]
she could go back into the kitchen and
be like hey fries are a hit and she
doesn't under now so I say that to this
day I said Joe are you [ __ ] kidding me
dude you just said these fries look good
now she's gonna go back with that
positive energy and maybe what if she
mentions it to the [ __ ] cook and we
liked
let me out do you like the fries do you
like the [ __ ] fries here all the time
he says uh yeah they're good yeah I just
thought these ones looked good I said
but you didn't rhyme so now when she
came back I said hey these fries were
temporary right and she said yeah I said
oh good because I love the other fries
and then she walked away and I said I
didn't want to do that I didn't want to
have to do that but I had to [ __ ] do
that because I had to level out his
idiocy with just blindly saying the
fries look good when you didn't even
[ __ ] who gives you [ __ ] what food
looks like so so I'm like I had to
[ __ ] save the day and be like yeah I
and he was like I'm just saying it look
I don't see the problem
and I said yeah okay well let me explain
something to you when you get the fries
here when you get the fries here
do you ever leave any of the fries on
the plate and he says well no and I said
then what the [ __ ] are you doing
you're a CUDA bro I looked at him right
in his face I said you're a CUDA I don't
even know if he knows what that means I
does know what it means cuz you know
he's my buddy but dude that's a CUDA
move to just see new fries bro to just
see new fries and get excited it was
like the end of [ __ ] and justice for
all dude I murdered him bro and he
understood I'm a good lawyer when it
comes to being at a diner I'm a good
lawyer I represent fries I'm a good
lawyer
I represent dude fries need do you need
a union representation fries I'm here
for you man
[Music]